hello and welcome to the shaky science
show in this video we'll look at can
your preteen predicts your biological
age and in particular we'll look at this
nature medicine paper here and discuss
how the human plasma proteome seems to
change during lifespan
now I mentioned aging a lot in this
channel as you can see from my previous
videos which you should check out by the
way but the thing is aging is a
predominant risk factor for several
chronic diseases that limit health span
and one really caring point that I often
make is that to better understand the
aging process we really need to have
biomarkers to identify the severity of
the aging process and so in the previous
video we looked at how epigenetic marks
could be used as a biomarker for
biological age but the thing is for
biomarkers we need something that is
gonna be predictive but also something
that can be easily taken from patients
causing minimal harm and also containing
lots of useful information
so besides epigenetics the proteome is a
good source of information because
proteins are often direct regulators of
cellular processes and pathways blood
samples would be good since they are
often taken from patients and we make
more blood cells on a daily basis and we
don't really notice the effects besides
formulas but like headers if we've
donated blood but are they're useful
biomarkers for Aging in the blood well
blood contains proteins that come from
cells and different tissues in the body
so they actually contain a wealth of
information but is this information
relevant and can it be related to you
aging so as I said in the opening and
this video we'll look at this nature
paper here where they have looked at the
human and plasma priam and how it
changes during lifespan and so the
plasma is just the soluble functional
blood and say those people notice that's
what they make completionists at there's
these undulating changes so I'm tracing
some interesting words or at least the
white I don't use very often so we had
to look it up but according to
dictionary.com
it can be used in such contexts such as
the dancer undulated her hips or the
flag undulates in the breeze I know for
example I quite liked was there were
stomachs thoughts and flats for also
undulating belly's soft and bloated from
the breakfast buffet
but I'm end of English lesson for today
and back to the science lesson hopefully
by the end of this video you'll be happy
to use the words undulating in the
context of the ageing human plasma
proteome so besides the blood containing
proteins why did the idea for this paper
come from well previous research from
the lab that also publishes paper
whereby they fused the circulatory
systems of young and old mice through a
process known as history chronic
parabiosis showed that when they did
this the aging phenotypes of the old
mouse scenes were fast so this includes
rejuvenation of liver lung hearts and
vein tissue and one factor in particular
that was thought to be involved in this
rejuvenation process was gdf 11 which
was in high levels in the young mouse
but in addition to there being potential
good factors are there also bad factors
in the old mice for example when old
mouse plasma was injected into young
mice they saw an acceleration of brain
aging say all in all these kind of these
experiments have shown that there's
something in the blood so what
information can we get from the blood
and relate that to aging processes all
right say back to the nature paper so
when this study they took four thousand
two hundred and sixty three individuals
that had ages from eighteen to 95 years
old and they analyzed the printing of
the plasma samples so how did you go
about detecting the protein in the
samples so in this study the team used
the same ask an optimal technology so
optimists are a fancy name for short
single-stranded oligonucleotides
and so these are legally presides they
can fold into a first range of really
intricate molecular structures and say
because they have these very specific
structures they can be designed to bind
with really high affinity to proteins
peptides and small molecules so this
famous kind optimal technology uses this
to its advantage and has a collection of
these different activities that
specifically recognize a protein of
interest and health on the other side a
dual ability to also bind
to capture probes that enable
quantification of the amount of protein
in the sample and what seems to be
unique to the soma scan technology is
that the apt moves have a slow off rate
and the technology has been designed
such that they can detect up to 5,000
different proteins in a plasma sample
considering we have 20,000 genes 5,000
proteins is a pretty decent number so
with the technology in hand the team
then looked at the protein of the
different individuals they had in their
cohort so by comparing the proteome from
people who were older to the individuals
who were younger in their cohort they
could see some proteins that were
significantly either higher in the older
samples or lower in the older samples so
I've highlighted a few ones here and
just to also briefly point out the full
data set is available online I'll put
the link for that in the description so
some of the significant proteins that
increase of age include sclerostin gdf
15 emmalin and scarf t and interestingly
they also saw CGA FSH B increase so this
was also noticed to be higher in females
and males particularly because this is
the follicle stimulating hormone so very
much um female hormone related but it's
interesting that this is really
significant and also demonstrates how
there might be sex specific aging
differences but this is just sharing the
aging proteome independent of sex I'm so
they also noticed an enrichment for
proteins in blood related pathways so
given that they've noticed these changes
in the pre tune during aging or at least
increase of life's pattern how you know
could this information be used to
develop a predictive measure or
someone's age based on their proteome in
the plasma a so-called proteomic aging
clock so using the plasma protein from
2008
17 individuals the team developed a
predictive model which they then tested
on 1446 individuals and they managed to
develop an accurate model using only 373
proteins and interestingly what they
noticed was some individuals that were
predicted to have a lower biological age
and the actual age also performance
better in physical and cognitive tests
so there seems to prove that the protein
does have the information to be able to
predict a biological age and to further
enhance their data set they also looked
at the plasma protein of mice as well
and what I noticed was they were
conserved preteens 46 in particular that
were conserved agent proteins and beef
to humans and mice plasma proteomes and
you can see these 46 conserved proteins
here I've highlighted both GED f11 and
GDS 15 because I mentioned them both
earlier but what are the striking things
you can see from this dataset is that
when these proteins change throughout
age from young to old and when for not
they go up or down in levels you can see
that it you know the changes aren't
occurring simultaneously globally you
have an undulating pattern this can also
be seen more clearly if I draw out how
the trajectories of the different
proteins change during age so you can
see that some go up some go down but
they also do this at different times and
at different rates
but despite the differences the
different trajectories of the proteins
can be grouped into eight different
clusters and globally what the different
clusters show is that most plasma
protein changes across the lifespan were
nonlinear and the number of proteins in
each cluster ranged from only eight to
more than 1,000 proteins in the cluster
so I've drawn up cluster seven and class
two eight here so we can see that
cluster seven seems to show this kind of
exponential increase as you get older
whereas plus the eight goes down in
terms of the protein levels during age
and by looking at
the pathways associated with the
proteins in the group in cluster seven
they see an association with
extracellular space I'm in cluster eight
they see a an association we have
receptor activity so in this case
they're seeing a decrease in receptor
activity and this is interesting and it
kind of shows that there are these
distinct changes in biological preys
disease that seems to be happening
during life span but the team wanted to
dig a little bit deeper into these
changes so what they did was a
differential expression
sliding-window analysis so as you can
see here what they did was they looked
at the proteome at specific intervals
and compared them so as I've drawn here
they use a window of twenty years and
they compare their pro teams and to
groups that are ten years apart so let's
say thirty five to forty five years
comparing that to forty five to fifty
five years and it's called siding one
day because you just do this in
increments of one year up and down the
different ages and so the idea behind
this analysis was to try and detect
changes at particular stages of life so
when are most of these changes in the
preteen McCarron what did the sequential
effects so they did this and here's a
graph I drew earlier and what they saw
was they saw that there are these three
peaks of significant pre-team changes
throughout age and these three peaks
occurred around thirty four sixty and
seventy eight years of age respectively
and so by then looking at the
association's of the preteens and the
different peaks they can see that the
peak of sixty years
shades associations with hormonal
activity binding functions and blood
pathways and blood pathways also came up
in the peak at around seventy eight
years but also been morphing genetic
protein signaling us as BMP signaling
and what what this really does show is
that this the aging process that's
detected from the plasma proteome shows
that agents dynamic it's a nonlinear
process and that you can see these these
waves of changes and that's really
interesting and kind of fascinating
about understanding the aging process
and for
by looking at the proteins and comparing
them to gnome genetic risk factors for
aging and age associated diseases they
saw that more the proteins were
associated with genetic factors in the
younger peak whereas the older Peaks
more the proteins for soft aiding or due
to environmental factors but the key
take-home really is that aging is
dynamic and at least in the proteome
shows these waves of changes these
undulating patterns you may see so next
time you see a flag waving in the wind
you can get look that flag is undulating
like the human plasma aging proteome
you'll sound pretty cool guaranteed well
well not guaranteed but I hope you will
agree that that does seem to be promise
for the proteome to be able to predict
your body weight and as always thanks
listening